hello and thank you for tuning in to my
talk today
i would like to thank the organizers and
the sponsors for putting together
this virtual meeting on cell and
developmental biology
my name is rebecca adeks and i'm a
postdoc in the madison martin labs at
stony brook university
and today i'll be talking about a
biosensor that we've adapted
to allow us to visualize the metazoan
proliferation
differentiation decision in vego
so during development embryos must both
increase in cellular number
as well as execute lineage-specific
cellular behaviors to give rise to their
final three-dimensional form
and the interplay between cellular
proliferation and morphogenesis
is critical to the successful completion
of developmental programs
multiple cell types across a diverse
range of organisms demonstrate a
potentially conserved requirement for
the cell cycle to be
arrested as a specific cell cycle phase
during specific morphogenic behaviors
and in fact defects in the cell cycle or
morphogenic movements are associated
with many pathogenic processes
and are regarded as hallmarks of cancer
metastasis so i'm interested in
understanding how the cell cycle is
regulated to
execute these different morphogenic
programs and in the long term we hope to
understand
how and if these programs are conserved
or how they have evolved
across the tree of life so to give you
some examples of different cell cycle
regulated behaviors
in the mattis lab we're interested in
understanding this particular cell in c
elegans denoted here
in cyan and this cell has to be held in
g1 g0
in order for it to invade through the
underlying basement membrane shown here
in magenta
neural crest delamination has been
debated upon what cell cycle state it is
in when it occurs but it has been shown
that these cells can delaminate and
migrate in
s phase epithelial tumor's ankle mold
transition
in this case which you're seeing here in
the developing tail bud of the zebrafish
embryo
has been shown to occur in g2
and cells that exit the cell cycle and
go into
g0 are quiescent differentiated or
senescent
so in order to understand how the cell
cycle is regulating these different
behaviors we have to be able to
visualize the cell cycle state live
so most of you are probably familiar
with the fuji
based system which is a two component
colorimetric based
sensor which allows you to distinguish
kind of g0 g1
versus sg2 however the
delineation between g0 and g1 and the
border between s and g2
are unable to be determined so we turned
to a ratio metric biosensor
which is a cdk2 biosensor which was
developed in the myer lab and um
a lot of work has subsequently done been
done in the spencer lab
looking at this uh cell cycle state
sensor
in tissue culture cells and the sensor
allows you to
look at the localization of the sensor
across the cell cycle
as it moves from a high concentration in
the nucleus
during g0 to highly excluded from the
nucleus
in g2 so this cell cycle state sensor
is at its n-terminus a fragment of the
dna
helicase b and this fragment contains
both a nuclear localization sequence and
a nuclear export sequence
and the nls is flanked by pairs of
serine residues
which can be phosphorylated by cdk
this is then hooked up to a fluorescent
protein so we can
assess the localization of this sensor
and
most of our constructs we've also
included
a viral cleavable peptide followed by a
histone mark so we can
use this as a nuclear mass
so in g0 g1 when cdk activity is low
the sensor will predominantly be
residing in the nucleus
and as cdk activity rises the sensor
will be phosphorylated this
phosphorylation event occludes the
nuclear localization sequence and the
nuclear export sequence dominates
leading to peak exclusion of the sensor
from the nucleus at g2
and so here just to show that again in
g0 you have a high amount of the sensor
in the nucleus
s phase will be about even between the
amount and the nucleus and the cytoplasm
and g2 you have exclusion of the sensor
from the nucleus and we can also put a
number on this
by taking the mean fluorescence
intensity of the cytoplasm and dividing
by the mean fluorescence
intensity of the nucleus
and so we wanted to adapt this sensor
for imaging in
in vivo systems and we started with c
elegans
um c elegans are an awesome model system
as they're easily genetically
manipulated
they're transparent and great for live
cell
imaging and additionally we know the
lineage
so we can follow a cell from the embryo
through the adult
and so here we've used a ribosomal
promoter rps27
to drive dhb expression along with
our histone marker and you can see that
uh
this expresses from the late embryo
through adult stages
and we've tried a variety of promoters
and fluorophores
so if you're interested um please look
at our pre-print or feel free to contact
me for more details
in the mattis lab we're particularly
interested in understanding this
particular region of the third larval
stage of c elegans or l3
and this region contains multiple
tissues uh the sm
which is the sex myoblast cells of the
somatic gonad the ventral uterine cells
or the somatic sheath cells
and the volvo precursor cells
and i hope what you can appreciate from
this image is that um
dhb is uh localizing to
uh various levels in the cytoplasm
versus the nucleus and different cells
and just to orient you here what you're
seeing is uh this is the nucleus
and this dark spot in the center is the
nucleolus so in c elegans a lot of
proteins
won't go into the nucleolus so when you
see that empty void that's what that is
and so hopefully you can appreciate that
this is reading out that these cells are
in fact in different states of the cell
cycle as we would expect
and so next we wanted to be able to
visualize
uh these dynamics over the course of the
cell cycle
and so here i'll bring your attention to
this volvo precursor cell
and during the course of this movie the
cell will go from one and divide into
two daughter cells and so here you can
see that this
is um in g1 as there's more in the
nucleus versus the cytoplasm
and as we follow this volvo precursor
cell it goes through s
g2 mitosis and then the two daughter
cells again will
have an increasing amount of
dhb in the nucleus as they go back to g1
and we can image many animals and assess
the ratio
of the cytoplasm to the nucleus to give
us a readout of cdk activity
and we can see here that from g1 to g2
before mitosis the cdk activity
increases and then they divide and um it
goes back to an increasing state here as
we know that this cell
will go on to divide again so we wanted
to ask the question
can we use this sensor to indicate
if a cell will in fact go on to divide
again or if a cell has
differentiated and so to do this we
continue to look at the
c elegans vulva so previously i'd shown
you this
first division here from one to two
cells
and um the volvo will go on to uh divide
uh two more times and this occurs during
the l3 to l4 stages
and however instead of giving rise to 24
cells
the two d cells denoted here by these
green circles
um terminally differentiate one
round of cell division early which
results in 22
cells which can pose the adult bulba
and these cells are denoted as
a through f symmetrically around the
vulva
and you can see here that strikingly um
that the amount of dhb in the nucleus of
these cells is very high
compared to the sister cells
and this d cell is the one that will is
terminally differentiated and the c
cell will go on to divide again for
example
and again we can quantify many cells
from many animals
um and we can see here that during this
cell division
the d cells exit at a cdk
low dhb ratio low whereas
the sister and cousin cells will go to a
cdk increasing state as they will divide
again before they terminally
differentiate
and here again i hope you can appreciate
that these d
cells have a high amount of the sensor
in their cytoplasm
compared to their nucleus which means
that they have terminally differentiated
whereas the sister cells
are continuing through the cell cycle
and then
later they will divide and be terminally
differentiated and therefore accumulate
the sensor in the nucleus
and so like i said the cd lineage is
special because one cell
differentiates whereas the sister cell
goes on to divide again
and if we look in wild type animals we
can see that here where both cells
exit cdk activity low
and the c cell immediately begins to
increase
in cdk activity before it divides again
and the d cell remains low
however when we were looking through
many animals we noticed something very
striking and i'll walk you through this
image here
so the cyan denotes the c cells and the
green stars denote the d cells and um
these two cells were born recently as
you can see there's a high amount of dhb
in the nucleus to the cytoplasm
indicating this
low cdk activity state and as these
cells progress
um this d cell will remain out and the c
cell will divide again
however if we look in the other side of
the animal we can see that the c
cell has begun to increase in cdk
activity
however it looks like maybe this d cell
also
is beginning to have a increasing amount
of cdk activity and we notice this
occurring in some very rare cases and
somewhere between
um two to ten percent of the population
based on um the
strain of c elegans we're looking at
where the d cell has higher cdk activity
than a g0
cell and so we decided to follow these
cells and see
what happened and in fact what we
observed was
is that these cycling d cells go on to
divide
and so i'll play this movie here and
then i'll walk you through the still
images
this is the c and d cell over here this
d cell will begin to
um increase in cdk activity and then it
will go on
to divide again
and so if we look at these still images
here we have our c
and our d cell on both sides of the
animal
and then this d cell will begin to
increase in cdk activity
whereas this d cell remains out is
terminally differentiated
this cell continues to enter the cell
cycle
and in fact divides gives rise to two
daughter
cells and then these daughter cells
remain with a cdk
activity low dhb ratio low state
and so if we plot all of these animals
where we observe this phenomena of the d
cell dividing we can see that they're
born into
a cdk increasing state which looks just
like their sister c
cell and these cells will go on to
divide again
and so this was very striking to us and
we're very excited to see this is it
really indicates that we can
in fact use um this as a way to predict
whether a cell will go on to divide
again or whether a cell
has entered g0 terminally differentiated
or quiescent
state and in looking into this we're
really excited to find that in fact this
observation had been made
back in 1986 by paul sternberg
where he had observed that a low
percentage of animals can have an extra
d cell division but we were able to
capture it with our sensor which was
very exciting
and so i've been able to show you that
the cdk biosensor dhb can read out cell
cycle state and it can allow us to
um observe this quiescence differential
differentiation decision in vivo
and so next what i'd like to do is to
tell you some of the
questions that were set up to answer in
the lab now and tell you a little bit
more about that
so um we want to be able to obviously
unmask novel cell cycle dynamics that
occur during development
and so one of the things that we're
interested in understanding and this is
the project of a graduate student taylor
in the lab
is looking at sulfate specification
decisions
and so in c elegans during the second
larval stage
there's this very classical fate
decision that makes sense where these
two cells decide what they're going to
become one becomes that anchor cell
which will invade
through the basement membrane later and
the other becomes a
ventral uterine cell and taylor has
preliminary data suggesting that this
fate specification decision is uh
tightly linked to the cell cycle
and as i mentioned before in the
beginning that anchor cell that we're
looking at which invades through the
basement membrane
must be held in g0 g1 in order to
undergo its invasive program
and now we're set up to uh really
look at the cell cycle state in those
anchor cells
and uh we know that perturbations that
prevent these cells from invading and
cause them to divide and enter the cell
cycle but now we can look more finely at
what specific cell cycle state these
cells are in
and what i'm particularly interested in
understanding
is um the regulation of the cell cycle
during cell migration
and so in c elegans there's this sex
myoblast cell
which provides a really nice model for
this so the cl against sex myolast or
the sm cell
is a migratory cell lineage and this sm
cell
is born um in a more posterior end of
the animal and then it will migrate 65
microns
to land at the center of the gonad and
this cell there's actually a
left right symmetry here so there's an
sm cell on either side of the worm
that migrates to the centers they flank
the gonad
each each cell will then undergo three
rounds at division
and they'll differentiate into the volvo
muscle and the uterine muscle cells
and so there'll be a total of 16 of
these cells in the animal
and these cells are required for
egg laying of the adult animal
and so we can visualize the sm cells um
here and we can see during the one cell
stage
and then they'll divide those three
rounds and then begin to terminally
differentiate
into the muscle cells
and so we can pair this sm cell uh
lineage tracer with our dhb cell cycle
state sensor and ask
what state of the cell cycle are these
cells in when they migrate
and so here we can see that we have a
high amount of dhb in the cytoplasm
to the nucleus suggesting that these
cells are in g1 or g0 when they migrate
and then obviously upon arrival they
begin to re-enter the cell cycle
as they'll divide
and so we just also followed these cells
as they went through subsequent rounds
of division and here i'm showing you
what the sensor looks like in a dividing
uh sex myogloss so we have one sm cell
here which will divide to two
it's currently in s phase it'll proceed
through g2
m and then give rise to two daughters
that are in
going into g1 here
and again we can compile multiple traces
across multiple animals and watch as
this cell divides from one cell
to two cells and goes to a cdk
increasing state before it divides again
and has a cdk increasing state and then
upon the terminal differentiation it
exits
cdk too low with a dhb ratio
of 0.22 and this is really exciting for
us because if you remember from before
we showed that migration is occurring at
a dhv value of
about 0.16
and this suggests that in fact this cell
is in g0
when it is migrating which is even lower
than its terminal differentiated g0
so i'm also interested in understanding
uh cell migratory behaviors and the
relation to the cell cycle
in other animals and so the next system
that we turn to look at
is the zebra fish and looking at the
zebrafish
migratory muscle progenitor lineage so
in zebrafish the mesodermal precursors
are
the pre-semitic mesoderm and during
development the peroxial musoderm
segments into these somites and the
formation of new somites requires the
continuous
addition of new cells and um these cells
are provided by the bi-potential
neuromesodermal progenitors in the
tailbone of the embryo
and um these neuromesodermal progenitors
or nmps
undergo a two-step um epithelial
tumescence
transition before they migrate and then
differentiate
into the somites and so in order to look
at this population
of migratory uh cells we needed to be
able to
adapt the sensor for expression in
zebrafish and so
here what we've done is hooked up the
heat shock promoter hsb70 to drive
expression
of dhb in the zebrafish and here you're
looking at
these early semitic structures and you
can see
that the cells are in all phases of the
cell cycle s
g2 and g1 can clearly be seen
here
and then if we look at animals at 72
hours
post fertilization when these cells have
terminally differentiated into their
myofibrils we can see that these cells
are now all in
g0 with a high amount in of the sensor
in the nucleus versus
the cytoplasm and we can quantify
multiple cells across the animal and we
can see here in the
early tailback during development we
have a range of dhb ratios as these
cells are
exhibiting in all phases of the cell
cycle and if we select out just those
cells in the tail bud which are in g1 we
get a value here
and we can compare this to terminally
differentiated
cells such as those in the myofibrils
which you're seeing here which gives us
the g0 value which is way lower than
this g1 value
so we can in fact read out the g0 g1
boundary in zebrafish as well and
additionally we wanted to be able to
show that this cell cycle
sensor is dynamic across the cell cycle
in zebrafish and so we've used spinning
disc confocal microscopy
to image from 10 to 12 hours of
development
imaging every five minutes five to seven
minutes
and um we can observe um cells here
even in the histone channel you can see
that some of these cells are dividing
and this can be correlated to the dhb
ratio and as i play this movie you can
watch as this
animal is developing from uh
gastrulation to segmentation
the tail bud is here on the bottom left
and the forming somites will be up here
on the top right
looking at the histones and the dhb and
so we can track the dhb
over developmental time and look
at the cdk activity of these cells in
the zebrafish
and we can do some higher resolution
microscopy to watch
individual cells dividing and really get
a
clearer quantitative analysis of the
activity
and so here i will just play this movie
and if you follow there's going to be a
cell
that will divide right here and so we
can track those cells over developmental
time
and begin to assess uh the cell cycle
state in all of these cells
and so now we're really set up to probe
questions to unmask novel cell cycle
dynamics during development in the
zebrafish so as i told you i'm
interested in understanding this
migratory cell lineage
um in the posterior growth zone of the
zebrafish and
the cells will undergo this epithelial
to mesenchymal transition and then
migrate to join the somites
and previous work has shown that this
population of cells must be in g2
um and in order to undergo this emt and
what's really exciting is
that we see populations of cells in the
tail bud that are in fact in g2
and so what we're going to set up to do
now is to pair
our sensor with transplantation assays
that will allow us to target specific
cell
lineages and assess the cell cycle state
of those cells
and so here you're looking at just the
neuromesodermal precursor cells and mps
um in a transplantation assay and you
can really nicely see individual cells
and assess their behavior
furthermore um the posterior growth zone
also offers other
cool biology for us to look at so
there's a conversion extension event
that happens um uh in the notochord that
the notochord arises from these midline
progenitor cells
and these midwelling progenitors are in
g1 which we can see
from our cell cycle state sensor and
just like we can do for the cells in the
tailbone we can also
look at these cells in these mosaic
transplantation assays
and something else that we're interested
in looking at is the
uh role that uh cell cycle plays in
regeneration as regeneration is the
reactivation of the cell cycle
in the groin glycemia or uh in the
quiescent stem cells
and we can use the larval fin fold of
the zebrafish to
assess the role of the cell cycle during
regeneration
and what we've done here is perform fin
clips at 48 hours post fertilization and
then this
is a time lapse that was taken in
collaboration with the betseg lab
and um we imaged at 17 hours post
amputation
every five minutes for about four hours
and this was
in the first round of these experiments
um and so we're really excited to follow
up
on these experiments as well and um
really be able to assess the cell cycle
state of the different populations
within the developing
within the regenerating finfold
and so with that i would also just like
to point out that we're really excited
to introduce the sensor into a whole
host of different organisms and a lot of
this
work has been in done in collaboration
with the embryology classes
um during the summer at mbl
um and so we've been able to introduce
uh the sensor into the slipper snail
caprijula
sea stars chicks and the matastella and
in collaboration with lance stevenson
we'd also been working
on looking at this cell cycle state
sensor during xenopus development
so with that i would just like to thank
um everyone
in the madison martin labs this project
has really been a huge team effort with
many people
uh contributing to its success and
i would like to thank my funding
for my post doctoral fellowship from
nigms
and with that i would like to thank you
all for listening to my talk
and just let you know if you have any
questions
um about this please reach out to me via
email my email is rebecca.edx at
stonybrook.edu
or feel free to reach out to me on
twitter my handle is at
r8x thank you